hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
dortmund ich mache heute etwas
herzhaftes und zwar gibt es leckere
pizza muffins und das ist was was wir
ganz gerne machen vor allen dingen wenig
besuch bekommen ich kann es nämlich gut
vorbereiten
man kann es warm und kalt essen und das
wird auch was was ihr zum beispiel für
eure halloween-party vorbereiten könnt
und dann eben an dem buffet servieren
könnt ich mache jetzt erstmal den
hefeteig und wehrt euch da die zutaten
zeigen und anschließend zeige ich euch
dann mit was ich die pizza muffins fülle
also für den hefeteig brauchen wir drei
100 gramm mehl das ist ganz normales
weizenmehl einwirken halben würfel hefe
ich habe da jetzt abgedeckt war gerade
so viel obst pflegen kommen als zu warm
draußen ist 150 milliliter wasser hat es
darf ein bisschen lauwarm sein einen
halben teelöffel zucker 30 milliliter öl
ich nehme es olivenöl weil das viel
besser schmeckt und natürlich brauchen
wir auch salz einen halben teelöffel ich
nehme auch ganz gern etwas pfeffer mit
rein
und wer möchte kann auch hier noch die
gewürze minze und oregano nehmen und ich
bereit daraus jetzt ein hefeteig zu und
nehme ich erstmal meine hefe und brösel
den hier eine kleine schüssel rein
das könnte jetzt mit einem mit einer
küchenmaschine machen aber ich mache das
jetzt einfach bei hatte sich ein ganz
kleiner teil
und so kann ich euch zeigen wie das ganz
einfach funktioniert hier gebe ich jetzt
ein bisschen wasser rein und zucker dann
kann die kirche nämlich gleich viel
besser aufgeht und das verriet jetzt ein
bisschen miteinander einfach dass ich
die hebe komplett auflöst und ich geh
jetz auch mal noch nicht komplett das
ganze wasser mit dazu dass so ein
bisschen was übrig
unternehmen jetzt hier mein mehrere und
gibt nach und nach mit rein so dass
einfach ein schöner hefeteig entsteht
und jetzt kommt erst das olivenöl mit
dazu das gebe ich nicht direkt mit rein
weil es einfach sonst verhindert dass
die hefe gut aufgeht
alles natürlich auch nicht vergessen und
wenn es nicht mehr im löffel geht nehmen
weil es einfach die hände und kneten den
schönen hefeteig drauf und dann auch
gerne etwas wasser dazu nehmen
ich nehme sich aus der schüssel raus
hier auf meiner arbeitsfläche so kann
ich das nämlich viel besser verkneten
und dann könnt ihr hier noch die
gewünschte mit dazu geben das mache ich
ganz gern weil dann der hefeteig etwas
würziger schmeckt und es wird ja gleich
ne pizza also eine pizza mafia und
deswegen finde ich das paar gewürze
unbedingt rein gehören die minister muss
ich immer ein bisschen zerkleinern die
ist nämlich aus unserem garten und da
nehme ich einfach jeweils so ein
teelöffel voll
das werde noch kurz ein geknetet dass es
sich einfach vollständig verteilt und
dann freue mich so eine kleine kugel
raus bestreicht sie mit etwas öl also
einfach hier auf die hände geben und so
gebe ich sehe nur eine schüssel rein und
lasst den hefeteig an einem warmen ort
aufgehen könnte auch einfach bei
zimmertemperatur stehen lassen so kall
ist es halt nicht
und jetzt werde ich gleich noch die
zutaten vorbereiten und zeigt ihr euch
kurz
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten die
ich jetzt für meine pizza muffins
verwende aber natürlich könnt ihr auch
ganz andere zutaten nehmen
aber das sind jetzt hier so meine
favoriten ich habe hier zum beispiel
etwas knoblauch wurst da habe ich jetzt
einfach die hier von bagdad genommen
weil die uns wirklich sehr gut schmeckt
und diese knoblauch wurst gibt es zum
beispiel im türkischen supermarkt oder
auch inzwischen schon in großen
supermärkten wie globus edeka oder rewe
die haben da auch schon dieses sortiment
von bagdad und das finde ich ganz
besonders gut weil man da einfach immer
gut dran kommt dann hab ich hier etwas
käse das ist ein gau da am stück den
nämlich auch immer ganz gern am stück
weil ich so die trennmittel dann im käse
nicht habe wenig geriebenen käse benutze
hier ein paar champignons eine paprika
hier habe ich getrocknete tomaten und
die sind aber auch in öl eingelegt also
das aufwändige von bagdad und da hat man
einfach immer schon den geschmack mit
dabei die sind in öl und kräutern
eingelegt aber es gibt auch tomaten die
ganz getrocknet sind die kann man auch
nehmen musste aber vorher in heißem
wasser ein bisschen auskochen damit sie
etwas weich werden
hier noch ein paar chili schoten könnten
aber auch milde pavarottis benutzen und
ein paar oliven die sind entsteint haben
aber hier diesen kern mit drin also
diesen paprika kern und diese zutaten
muss ich jetzt alle fein würfeln und das
mache ich jetzt eben schnell bei der
knoblauch es muss darauf achten dass die
haut weg muss die darf mit nicht mit
verzehrt werden und zwar kann man die
einfach hier so runter schälen am besten
irgendwo ansetzen und dann die haut
entfernen
und jetzt werde ich sie entscheiden und
in kleine würfel schneiden und die hat
einfach einen richtig schönen würzigen
geschmack und deswegen nehme ich dir
ganz gern man könnte aber zum beispiel
auch einfach etwas salami nehmen
und weil es ja sowieso später alles
vermischt wird gebe ich einfach alles
zusammen in eine kleine schüssel mit
rein und dann nehmt ihr einfach so viel
wie ihr möchtet bei mir reicht es die
halbe menge
jetzt nehme ich hier noch ein paar
champignons
schneit die auch erst in scheiben und
dann in würfel und bei standen uns müsse
darauf achten dass man die nicht waschen
darf unter wasser weil sie sich dann
voll saugen mit wasser sondern wenn sie
etwas schmutzig sind dann einfach mit
einem küchenpapier ein bisschen abtupfen
ich komme jetzt auch mit rein ein
bisschen viele wie lege ich mir mal weg
die nämlich später für was anderes
dann die tomaten diese natürlich etwas
glitschig weil sie in öl eingelegt sind
aber man kann sie super schneiden weil
sie sehr weich sind und ich finde die
getrockneten tomaten sind uns so eine
zutat sie müssen auf jeden fall mit rein
weil sie dem ganzen etwas aroma geben
vor allem wenn ihr die pizza muffins
vegetarisch macht und zb die salami oder
die knoblauch wurst fehlt fehlt ja auch
so ein bisschen der geschmack und es
gibt eben die tomate dann dem teig
zurück heute ist übrigens der murat
nicht da moment an der stelle aber
hinter der kamera steht meine freundin
carina und die bringt im rahmen des
power film und also das filmen weil mein
murat ist ja so ein bisschen verrückt
und somit immer raus und das wollen wir
jetzt ein bisschen verhindern und die
karima zeigt ihm das dann immer ganz
schön bei den chinesen ist der
auffassung die sind wirklich ein
bisschen scharf also bei uns wir mögen
alle ganz gern scharf und deswegen essen
wir das gerne aber wenn ich scharf mag
nimmt lieber ein paar millionen ist
ich nehme jetzt nicht alle weil die
sanierer später vielleicht noch mit ist
und sie ist auch nicht so scharf
ja die carrer marken vermehren das weiß
ich ich glaube du hast ja auch immer so
deine gewürzmischung mit dabei der mühle
oder annimmt da wirklich einfach zutaten
die ihr gehabt meist wird jetzt auch
ganz gut gehen das mag die familie auch
immer gerne oder was fällt dir ein
hast du irgendwas
ja meistens lecker manche mögen ja auch
ananas auf der pizza oder schinken oder
keine ahnung was mozzarella werde jetzt
auch ganz gut so
die paprika wie vergessen da nehme ich
jetzt auch nur einen kleinen teil
sonst wird es alles zu viel und am
besten umdrehen so lässt sie sich besser
schneiden und dann auch einfach fein
würfeln
den käse könnte jetzt entweder fein
würfeln oder fein reiben
ich werde ihn jetzt kurz reiben weil es
sich so besser im teig verteilt man dann
einfach kleinere stückchen hat könnte
die aber auch in den mixer reinstecken
also irgendwie einfach verkleinern und
da nehme ich jetzt so eine handvoll käse
das reicht dann auch könnte man zum
beispiel auch einen fetakäse nehmen das
mag ich auch gerne
aber mein mann nicht mehr so weil ich
eben eine väter shop gegeben habt da gab
es jede woche irgendwie fehlt ablesen
ich freue mich hier ganz kurz auf mein
tages schon aufgegangen und dann stellen
wir die pizza muffins auch gleich fertig
so ich habe jetzt bereits meine muffin
form vorbereitet
ich nehme eine ganz normale machen form
und habe sie bereits mit meinem back
transport eines eingesprüht und hier
könnt ihr auch etwas butter nehmen oder
öl aber ich muss gern mit dem spray weil
es einfach sehr schnell geht aber ihr
müsst es auf jeden fall einfetten weil
der hefeteig verklebt und papier
backförmchen würde ich da jetzt nicht
benutzen weil sonst müsst ihr das papier
später vom hefeteig wieder runter
kriegen meint ist schön aufgegangen das
sieht man ihr und den nehme ich jetzt
hier heraus und er löst sich auch was
komplett aus der schüssel weil wir sie
vorher eingefettet hatten dann breite
ich den tag einfach ein bisschen aus und
geht hier jetzt die füllung drauf als
ich hab heute ein bisschen viel füllung
aber das ist nicht schlimm dass kriege
mannes darunter mit einfacher zeit
geknüpft und es riecht auch einfach wie
eine pizza
obwohl jetzt keine tomatensoße drin
steckt aber ziehen hat so diese
mediterranen zutaten und jetzt wird es
einfach hier ein geknetet am besten
erstmal hier ein rollen dann machen wir
jetzt hier nicht so eine große sauerei
und dann einfach ein paar mal zusammen
falten und dann sollte sich das alles
verbunden haben
und je nachdem wie viele zutaten jetzt
hinzugefügt habt kann es sein dass ihr
12 oder einfach mehr muffins raus
bekommt dann nimm dir jetzt einfach eine
tankkarte oder ein messer und
funktioniert die jetzt ab falls sie zu
einer kleinen kugel und dann werden sie
einfach indem auf in form reingesetzt
und wenn ihr zum beispiel wirklich die
muffins für eine party oder so machen
wollt wenig ist es eine gute größe oder
ihnen die kleineren muffin förmchen und
habt richtig kleine häppchen dann kann
man praktisch die muffins mit einem
schluck verschlingen
mit einem biss verstehen so sieht es
dann in meiner muffin form aus ich habe
es noch einen kleinen rest übrig also
das in etwa so zwei mal findet ihr noch
übrig sind die mache ich dann danach und
diese muffins lasse ich jetzt aber
erstmal noch aufgehen damit so richtig
schön locker werden und nach dem
aufgehen zeige ich euch noch mal und
dann können wir sie direkt backen die
pizza muffins schön aufgegangen man
sieht dass sie schön locker werden und
jetzt werden sie bei etwa 220 grad für
ungefähr 25 minuten gebacken bis sie
einfach eine schöne farbe haben und was
ich jetzt hier ganz besonders schön
finde dass wir hier eben auch die
zutaten außen haben und ich mag es zum
beispiel wenn die tomaten dann schön
knusprig werden oder das trug also in
knoblauch wusste schön knusprig wird und
deswegen finde ich die ganz besonders
lecker aber entschädigt erstmal in open
und zeigt ihr euch dann einfach gleich
die muffins gebacken und ich habs jetzt
auch etwa 23 minuten abkühlen lassen
damit wir uns jetzt nicht verbrennen
morath und samira sind übrigens auch
schon auf dem weg und so sehen die
muffins dann aus wie setze ich jetzt
hier mal auf eine platte
und wie gesagt könnte man sie jetzt
abkühlen lassen und servieren
oder eben so wie wir sie jetzt elfter
werden gewarnt und hier sieht man auch
schön was ich vorhin gemeint habe dass
eben hier die tomaten und die knoblauch
wurst ein bisschen dunkel werden und an
geräumt werden und das finde ich ganz
lecker die sind zwar noch ein bisschen
heiß aber magst du probieren
nein ich zeige euch mal eins jetzt
verbrenne ich mich gleich
dies von innen aussieht es sehr heiß und
man sieht einfach dass der teig richtig
schön locker ist und die zutaten schön
verteilt sind jedermann findet übrigens
anders aus als wir werden jetzt nicht
alle gleichmäßig hoch weil er mal mehr
und mal weniger zutaten drin habt aber
ich finde schmecken und riechen
je nachdem was ihr eben für zutaten
rhein gibt und wir werden uns die
muffins noch schmecken lassen warten
noch auf morath und samira das rezept
gibt es dann zum nachlesen auch sallys
blog.de und ich würde mich freuen wenn
ihr mir ein paar fotos auf facebook oder
instagram schickt ich werde übrigens
auch mal noch eine richtige pfizer
machen als mit richtigen boden und belag
und so weiter
die pizza eben ist und eigentlich habe
ich schon alles gesagt ich freue mich
gut daran erinnert und zwar werde ich am
30 oktober auf der messe in karlsruhe
sein mit der liebe nicole von nicole
zuckerberg und da gibt es dann viele
leckereien von uns und ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr uns da alle besuchen
kommt wir sind da von 10 bis 18 uhr
damit an einen tag einen sally stand und
da gibt es dann auch was herzhaftes und
süßes zum probieren
da können uns ein bisschen kennenlernen
ich würde mich auch freuen wenn ganz
viele von euch erscheinen dann habe ich
mal ein paar gesichter von euch zu den
namen mit dazu so war es ja auch beim
globus schon und da wird es nicht ganz
ab freuen wenn wir uns das sehen
vielleicht könnte das auch in die
kommentare schreiben bekommen kann und
wer uns besucht ich freu mich schon
drauf bis zum nächsten mal